hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2022 american drama and comedy movie
called sex appeal
the movie begins with an overachieving
high school teen named avery hansen
white who excels at things she's good at
meaning that she will avoid things she
knows she won't fit in
furthermore she has a record-breaking
gpa and got an early acceptance to mit
however she doesn't care about having a
lot of friends and she doesn't even want
to attend the prom as she claims that
steam con or stem competition is her
prom
this year steemcon challenges avery to
design an app to solve a personal
problem in her life
after school avery meets her best friend
larson who has been her subject of
experiment since childhood despite him
not having passion in science their
partnership eventually has to come to an
end after the teenager larson attempts
to kiss her but he gets punched instead
despite having no appeal at all in a
relationship avery turns out to have a
long-distance boyfriend named casper
that he met in the steam con
when being asked whether she brings him
to the school prom she answers that prom
is not on her priority at all
thus larson implicitly persuades her to
go to prom with him but the offer gets
rejected
in her house avery brainstorms and
suddenly realizes that there is nothing
to improve in her life since she has no
area of weakness at all
not long after she receives a video call
from casper who wants to bring their
relationship to the next level when they
meet at steamcon later
avery panics and she immediately shuts
down her laptop as sexual stuff is the
only stuff she knows nothing about avery
was raised by three moms who are susie
deb who is renowned for her legendary
art and bonus mom kim
because of that she has no one to turn
to for advice on adult stuff with men
she then goes to mom susie and tells her
about her boyfriend's intention telling
her that she is also thinking about
doing it later
she gives her advice saying that sexual
stuff should be messy not to be perfect
at every move
avery returns to her room and concludes
that she will create a smart application
to help her become master at adult stuff
and she will also use it for a guide
through her first sexual experience with
her boyfriend later
she starts programming the ai and the
algorithm but she later realizes that
she needs some experiments and finds
additional data
the next day she attends a sex ed class
but the teacher refuses to help her she
approaches mom susie for the second time
who offers a copy of fifty shades of
grey book and other similar books to her
but she rejects them the mom then
suggests she collects the data from her
fellow friends at school which she
agrees to do she begins interviewing
several classmates starting from
cheerleader dancer bodybuilder engineer
student
however all of them don't have
experience and don't have the urgency in
doing so thus they suggest avery talks
to school start danica mccallum
after school she approaches danica who
gives avery a lot of insights about
adult stuff including her size
preference and suggests she finds a
partner to practice with
she agrees with that and immediately
comes to larson asking him to hook out
with her every day in her house which
makes everyone in the room confused
larson escorts him out of the classroom
and initially refuses the offer because
avery friend-zoned him and besides she
has a boyfriend
she keeps convincing and tempting him
until he cannot resist and agrees to be
her experiment partner again despite him
having a crush with another girl
currently a few moments later the pair
arrive at larson's room where he is told
to follow a protocol that has been
pre-written in a paper
before they start larson mentions that
love is what makes a good lover but
avery denies that hypothesis saying that
love and sexual stuff are different
entities
afterwards she orders larsen to kiss her
which he does and he plays music to make
the atmosphere better
they cuddle while enjoying the song
until avery asks him to move his hand
under her shirt for the first time in
her life avery feels an outstanding
pleasure getting touched by a man until
larson crosses the line and she decides
to leave the room
at home she continues building the
algorithm for the application
the next day avery visits a potter and
interviews more classmates to understand
more about man's genital system
after learning more about it now she
can't even get her sight out of it since
it is everywhere in her daily life
she eventually comes back to larson's
place where she claims that she needs to
touch his things to get a hands-on
experience
as expected he allows her to do so and
she starts examining it thoroughly
the scene suddenly moves to a place
where larson is acting as an astronaut
who is ready to take off while avery
keeps pumping the fuel to the spacecraft
after a while the spacecraft takes off
and larsen screams in happiness
he then offers avery to return the favor
but she gets it wrong and tells him she
needs to get back to analyze the data as
today's experiment is successful
she realizes that there is still some
gap in her data so she visits danica who
teaches the nerd girl how to touch
herself suggesting she pictures her
object of desire
following danica's suggestion avery
returns home and directly goes to the
bathroom where she uses the water stream
as a tool
while she is enjoying herself suddenly
the water becomes hotter and she has to
apply a cold compress between her thighs
soon larson calls her warning her not to
think too much about something that
happens naturally but avery changes the
topic
she suggests that they have a dirty talk
on the phone larson tries to bring up
several topics to turn her on but it
seems like nothing works until he talks
about periodic tables and stuff she
would achieve after graduating from mit
she enjoys the topic until larson
mentions about her winning steam con and
suddenly carlson shows up while holding
the trophy which ruins the entire mood
it's eight days remaining before steam
khan and avery tries to interview
several classmates during the math class
one of the classmates frank talks about
erogenous zones in a very specific way
until a woman sitting in the back marla
randomly offers to pleasure herself to
prove the discussion
the teacher eventually is distracted
with them but it seems like the students
manage to disguise the adult topic into
mathematics stuff which makes the
teacher very happy
meanwhile marla keeps doing her stuff
until she reaches the peak and screams
in happiness
after class larsen and avery rushed to
the man's place to practice what she has
discussed and discovered earlier in math
class
the scene moves to larsen acting as a
digger descends into a narrow colorful
tunnel
he starts exploring the tunnel while
occasionally touching the wall
this action triggers avery until he
finds a door which teleports them into
the swimming scene and avery enjoys that
moment
afterward she then comes up with a name
for her application sex appeal larone
attempts to bring their knight into the
next level but again avery denies it
saying that their action needs to remain
professional and focusing on the
experiments which disappoints him he
then hypothesizes that chemistry is
achieved when love meets sexual stuff
and vice versa but she disagrees stating
that love has nothing to do with sexual
experiences
avery compiles all the data and finally
finishes the application on time
one night before steam con larson
approaches avery and asks her to go to
the science museum with him but as
expected the girl declines the
invitation
he questions her feelings towards him
since they have been doing a lot of
stuff together but her answers
disappoint him so he decides to go there
alone despite having two tickets with
him the next day avery realizes that she
feels something different towards larsen
but she denies the feelings
after casper's presentation they
immediately head over to the hotel room
and the pair starts doing stuff by
following the suggestion from her
application
however avery doesn't enjoy the moment
as she did with larson even after
following all the directions
not long after she decides to stop the
intercourse and leaves the room
at this moment she realizes that she has
fallen in love with larson
the following morning avery withdraws
her presentation because she knows that
the application didn't work for her so
she walks out from the stage in tears
this leads to disqualification and
casper automatically becomes the winner
of the competition
that night she pays a visit to larsen
who is already fed up with her stating
that he has had enough with the false
hope given to him and he is done waiting
for the moment she changes her mind
about him
he realizes that avery never cares about
anyone especially him so he is glad that
he didn't have to sleep with her
she then looks back at the interviews
she had conducted and finally believes
that love and sexual experience are
actually intertwined
the following day mom kim comes to her
room suggesting she speak from her heart
and be honest to larson
she does
she interrupts larsen who is practicing
music and admits that his hypothesis
about love and sexual experience are
correct
however this action just makes her look
silly and he has to escort him out avery
finally reveals her true feelings to him
but it is already too late as larson
makes it clear that he has moved on from
her
she offers him to go to prom with her
but he is not interested at all
at the end avery states that she loves
him but he walks away in silence while
crying in loneliness she is approached
by a teacher who teaches her a life
lesson which makes her feel much better
at the prom night larson is seen dancing
with his crush while avery just can
observe from a distance alone
but this time she realizes that not
everything can be forced and she feels
happy for him
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching